building your infrastructure or hosting
your application in the cloud can be
tricky one misconfiguration and your
cost could quietly creep up or even
skyrocket your performance could slow to
a crawl or you could have holes in your
security big enough to cause some
serious trouble
it can be difficult to stay on top of
things but you don't have to do it alone
today i'm going to tell you about
activeassist the intelligence baked into
google cloud that helps you troubleshoot
configure and optimize your
infrastructure with ease so what is
activeassist
well it's not just one thing it's a
portfolio of tools and services that
span across google cloud
activasys combines data intelligence and
machine learning to provide you with an
array of tools specifically tuned to
your usage these tools are designed to
reduce the complexity of managing
infrastructure in the cloud
the activist portfolio includes the
recommendation hub and an api as well as
a collection of recommenders let's break
down what recommenders are and how they
work
recommenders offer personalized
intelligent insights and recommendations
for various google cloud resources and
services based on your usage data these
recommendations expose opportunities to
fine-tune and optimize your
configuration in various areas
for example if you run virtual machines
on compute engine you can reduce costs
by shutting down or deleting any virtual
machines that aren't actively being used
the idle vm recommender will let you
know when a virtual machine is idle or
unused
recommendations are made on based on
cloud monitoring data and are
continuously being updated
another example is enforcing the best
practice of least privilege this
includes making sure that users only
have the permissions that they actually
need and use
the iim recommender will spot any excess
permissions granted to any accounts and
offer alternative roles and permissions
to grant instead
to view or manage recommendations users
will require the appropriate iam roles
corresponding to the type of recommender
that they need access to
these permissions are also bundled in
some roles like the owner role that way
you can delegate the visibility and
management of recommendations to
different users or teams once you have
access to recommendations there's a
number of ways that you can view and
manage them
first you might see them in context on
the pages for the services that they
correspond to
for example you'll see iam policy
recommendations at the top of the iam
and admin page and next to any accounts
that might have access permissions in
the same way the compute engine vm
instances page will tell you when there
are machine type recommendations at the
top of the page and next to any machines
that the recommendations apply to
this visibility ensures that
administrators for these services don't
miss any of the latest recommendations
that could positively impact the
organization
recommenders can also be accessed from
the cloud console via the recommendation
hub where you can view dismiss or apply
recommendations with just a few clicks
in the recommendation hub each
recommender will display with a card
with its description and a summary of
the recommendations that it's generated
along with the impact of actually
applying those changes you can click
view all for any recommender to see more
details about the individual
recommendation
recommendations can also be accessed
from the gcloud command line interface
for more advanced and programmatic
management
accessing recommendations to the cli
reveals additional information and
properties such as priority and primary
impact category these properties are
helpful in identifying recommendations
that could have the biggest effect on
costs performance and security
by familiarizing yourself with some of
the features of activeassist you can
reduce the complexity of running in the
cloud a great place to start is getting
to know all the different recommenders
that active assist has to offer
collectively recommenders will equip you
to do six things successfully
manage your cost wisely maximize the
performance of your systems mitigate
your security risk proactively deliver
high availability and reliable services
to your end users
spend less time managing your cloud
configuration and reducing the carbon
footprint of your workloads
in the next few videos we're going to
focus primarily on three areas costs
performance and security
then we'll take a look at how we can
manage recommendations across multiple
projects inside of a single organization
stay tuned for the next video where we
start by taking a look at what
recommenders can do for cost
optimization see you there
you